DINA PORTMAN: Hey, Martin,
what are you wearing?
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh hi, Dina.
This is from an
e-commerce startup.
Their dev team is
evaluating Cloud Run
for nine different
types of workloads.
I told them we'd find
the answers for them.
DINA PORTMAN: Sounds great.
Stay tuned if you
want to know more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: Artizanship
connects rural artisans
with consumers worldwide.
My new hat came from Ecuador.
Their dev team is
excited about Cloud Run,
but they aren't sure if
it's a good fit for them.
Here, I have a list of
nine types of workloads.
Dina, could you tell me
if Cloud Run would be
a good fit for those workloads?
DINA PORTMAN: Sure,
I'll do my best.
What's the first one?
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
they want to build
private microservices
that communicate
with each other asynchronously.
DINA PORTMAN: Cloud Run
would be a great fit.
It would scale each service
up and down, independently
and automatically.
The services would communicate
securely with each other
through Cloud Pub/Sub.
And the service endpoints would
be secured by authentication.
If they prefer services to
explicitly call other services,
they should use Cloud
Tasks instead of Pub/Sub.
The calls are still
robust and asynchronous,
but developers get more control
over things like retries,
scheduling, and rate limits.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
workload number two,
a public REST API using HTTPS.
DINA PORTMAN: Oh, easy.
They go to REST Service in Cloud
Run which provides an HTTPS
endpoint out of the box.
They can also add their own
custom domain on this endpoint.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
workload number three,
scheduled maintenance jobs.
DINA PORTMAN: They can trigger
their Cloud Run services
from Cloud Scheduler.
Cloud Scheduler is
also serverless,
and it uses the standard
Unix cron format.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
workload number four.
They get data feeds from
suppliers in different formats.
The data needs to be transformed
and loaded into their database.
DINA PORTMAN: It's easy to
build ETL services in Cloud Run
and trigger them when files
are uploaded to Cloud Storage.
Another alternative would be
to let Cloud Data Flow send
each record to
their Cloud Run ETL
service as a Pub/Sub message.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
workload number five.
Oh, they need a public
website, of course.
DINA PORTMAN: Well, they can
run a web framework, like Flask
or Express, on Cloud Run.
If their website runs
on a software package,
they may be able
to use Cloud Run.
WordPress, for example,
works on Cloud Run,
but it requires
extra configuration.
The team should also
check out App Engine,
which is a mature product for
building scalable web apps.
Many content management
systems are also
available in the
GCP Marketplace.
From the Marketplace,
you can deploy
production-grade solutions
to Compute Engine
with just a few clicks.
There are images for WordPress,
Magento, Joomla, Drupal, et
cetera.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
workload number six.
Oh, one of their microservices
create product images
using a binary library.
DINA PORTMAN: Oh,
Cloud Run can do that.
They would package up the
binary in a Docker container
and call it from the code.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very well,
workload number seven.
They also render video files
of some of their products.
These jobs can
take hours to run.
DINA PORTMAN: Well,
a Cloud Run job
can run for a maximum
of 60 minutes.
Some long-running jobs can
be split into shorter jobs,
and this may simplify the code
and enable parallel processing.
But if their jobs
can't be split up
and if they take
more than 60 minutes,
the team should use Compute
Engine or Kubernetes Engine.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
workload number eight,
off-the-shelf software
package for their finances
and warehouse management.
DINA PORTMAN: Any
software or binary
that can run in
a Linux container
and does not store data on
disk can run in Cloud Run.
If their finance or
warehouse software
can't run in a Linux
container, they
can run it on Compute
Engine, instead.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
workload number nine,
the final one.
This is a product
recommendation engine
that will use machine learning.
DINA PORTMAN: They should
use Recommendations AI
or another product in
Google's IA platform.
But a Cloud Run
service can still
call those services to get
recommendations or even run
custom machine learning models.
MARTIN OMANDER: Well, those
are all nine services.
You seem awfully
well-prepared, Dina.
Did you peek at my list?
DINA PORTMAN: Well,
perhaps, but only a little.
MARTIN OMANDER: [LAUGHS] We
hope you enjoyed this episode.
[MUSIC PLAYING]